formel 1 freunde 54 sekunden rückstand
für sebastian vettel beim ersten grand
prix in australien in melbourne im
albert park
das nennt man wohl eine klassische
deklassierung vierter platz viel zu weit
weg keine chance gegen mercedes auch
gegen red bull nicht letztendlich ist
das einzige was für vettel vielleicht
ein bisschen erfreulich sein kann das
nicht hamilton gewonnen hat sondern
valtteri bottas der finne der extrem
stark gefahren ist
die frage ist also kann er
möglicherweise hamilton aufhalten in
diesem jahr das werden erst die nächsten
rennen zeigen aber vettel nahm diesen
ball gleich auf auch ferrari dürfe und
solle man nicht abschreiben
vielleicht lag es an den reifen vettels
jedenfalls brachen ziemlich einem
mittelteil des rennen waren dann so
verbraucht dass sogar der junge clark
sein teamkollege immer näher kam und
näher kam
bis zur 50 runde und jeder wohl dachte
nun jetzt kommt das überholmanöver
plötzlich stiegen die rundenzeiten von
leader und man kann sich vorstellen
aus reinem respekt gegenüber dem
viermaligen weltmeister aus deutschland
ist das nicht geschehen
da kam wohl das durch was sich schon im
vorfeld der saison abzeichnete eine art
teamorder dass daten hat noch einmal
gezeigt wie gut er ist aber dass auch
der red bull mit dem honda motor eben
vorangekommen ist er lag 20 sekunden vor
ferrari und das bedeutet eben dass
ferrari nicht wirklich ein team order
probleme hat sondern ganz massiv 1 mit
dem auto oder mit dem reifen so genau
wissen sie das noch nicht einer der
ihnen ein bisschen dabei entgegen
gekommen ist es der teamchef von
mercedes toto wolff der sagte ja man
wisse ja gar nicht worum man selbst so
schnell sei man wisse übrigen auch nicht
warum ferrari so langsam gewesen sei
wenn man das jetzt ernst nimmt was er
sagt dann müsste man sicher sagen dass
diese wissens experten der formel 1
nicht möglich wissen was eigentlich hier
in der formel1 geschieht dass sie
möglicherweise viel zu komplex ist auch
für die eigenen ingenieuren
ich habe da meine zweifel wir werden
sehen ende märz im nächsten rennen was
daraus wird es wird uns antworten geben
aus dem komplexen gebilde der formel 1